S'il y a 1 choix à faire aujourd'hui
entre l'Algérie et le Maroc,
moi je choisis le Maroc.
Moi, ça fait des années
que je dis que l'accord avec l'Algérie
que nous avons doit être complètement déviable,
surtout s'il ne change pas d'attitude.
Et avec le Maroc, il faut qu'on sorte aujourd'hui
de cette glaciation diplomatique.
Le Maroc est 1 pays ami historiquement,
il faut qu'on rétablisse des relations normales
et c'est à nous de faire les efforts nécessaires et
d'être clair, notamment sur la question du Sahara.
S'il y a 1 choix à faire aujourd'hui
entre l'Algérie et le Maroc,
moi je choisis le Maroc.
Surtout quand on voit l'attitude des Algériens
et du président algérien
qui n'a pas hésité
à faire remettre dans l'hymne algérien
1 couplet anti-france au bout d'un moment,
il faut aussi encore 1 fois mettre 1 coup d'arrêt
à cette euh, à cette dérive